mother's father's children these are the
faces of those who went missing when the
Manchester bomb exploded 15 year-old
Olivia Campbell was at the concert with
her friend her family has been searching
local hospitals in hope of news found
out that the explosion
we tried ringing alway Ollie wasn't
answering her for in the forum was dead
we then tried to a friend and a friend
down to the fall and basically the
suddenly of the iron was shouting we
need a paramedic need a paramedic and
his form went dead and from then on we
tried ringing him again and his form was
completely dead and they phoned the lab
but he's in intensive care so we can't
even speak to him to see whether they
got split up as we are filming her
stepbrother was told she's not being
treated here it's hard working in the
minute the family just in bits and we've
got all the family around that they
asked at the minute and the movies just
saw down with on or what to do it then
it was just all worried they just wander
on and devastating at the minute well
some search on foot others have turned
to social media the hashtag missing in
Manchester is being shared around the
world the stadium has been set up as a
missing-persons center and throughout
the day families have been coming here
and logging details with the police in
the hope that their loved ones will be
found for survivors like Alicia the
trauma of the night is raw she was at
the concert with her housemate the
children sitting behind her disappeared
now I've not slept in or or a or
anything because I just can't stop
thinking about it and then as soon as I
stopped thinking about it it just goes
back into my mind again you just hear
the screams and see the people run in
it's just like a variety of noise like
mainly screaming but also people just
calling out for the loved ones like but
unique people shouting where's my mommy
like I can't find my mom I just think
she don't want help I just didn't know
what to do did you see all those
children get out that you saw
you know I don't I don't really know
what happened to them
while this city refuses to be cowed by
terror the pain caused by this attack is
widespread and profound Siobhan Robbins
Sky News in Manchester